We start here at the cone.
This is an efficient, humane,
fast way to get it done.
We use garden snips and you can use a sharp knife.
I can't show you the actual process here.
You'll see his feet is still moving,
but he has passed on. Nerves, um,
built up in the tendons and muscles will still move after.
Hence the term running around like a headless chicken.
That process takes literally less than a couple seconds.
Um, and the chicken had no idea what was coming next.
I'm gonna dip the chicken in 150 degree water with some dish soap.
This helps remove the feathers so it gets into the skin.
The temperature opens the pores
and this helps the chickens feathers release from the skin.
This is something we invested in
as we will be planning on raising more chickens for meat.
But you can also rent these.
This makes removing the feathers pretty easy.
This takes anywhere from a minute to five minutes to do each bird.
You can put multiple birds in here at the same time
and that also helps them tumble around better. Here.
The feet skin didn't come off perfectly
because I didn't dip the feet in enough into the hot water,
which is fine.
I just wasn't particularly wanting to keep the feet of this bird.
I give the bird a rinse off
and then I did notice
this one had a little bit more fuzzy feathers underneath the wing.
Which happens sometimes, so I just removed those by hand.
Now everyone has their own way of butchering a chicken.
This is just the way I do it.
I start by cutting off the feet.
To get the feet off
you just need to cut the skin and tendons around from the joint
and then kind of they will just release once you got those tendons.
Now a lot of people would think
what in the world would you do with a chicken foot?
But you can definitely still eat them.
They're great for making broth,
which you can then make soups with,
so definitely not throw them.
In a way. They also make great dog treats.
There's no reason to waste any part of the chicken.
You can pretty much use every part of the chicken
except the intestines. Although
I have seen in the comments that some people still eat the intestines,
which is kinda interesting.
Sounds kinda gross, but I know obviously that sausages are made out of,
um. Pig intestines.
Um, so yeah,
back in the day
people used to use every part of the animal for something.
I've just never heard of anyone actually using chicken intestines,
but I will look into that.
Now we're on to removing the crop.
Now this is the most tedious part of the whole process for me.
The crop is slippery, slimy,
and kinda hard to grab hold of.
You need to remove it
and it's attached to the Breast and to the neck by membranes.
And it's very hard to remove.
But you don't wanna use a knife.
I'm just to run my fingers through here,
try to get my finger between the, um,
crop and the other parts of the chicken.
And I'm pretty much just gonna use my hands
and pressure to remove this.
If you use a knife, you can risk punching in the crop
and that just makes a mess.
Um, it is pretty simple.
It's just a process. I'm gonna pull on that crop
and it did release from the organs inside.
I snipped it off and put it in the gut bucket.
Now I'm gonna move on to removing the internal organs.
I'm gonna make a slight cut and have that knife facing outwards.
And I'm gonna use my hands to rip over the cavity.
This way I don't punch or any of the internal organs.
This is really important because this is where the bacteria,
like salmonella is could be present,
and I don't want that to go on the meat.
I'm gonna gently
but firmly grab hold of these organs and pull them out.
They are attached
and they have membranes kinda holding them to the cavity.
I'm just running my hands through that to pull them out
and break up those membranes.
There is the gizzard right there.
Some people like to eat that.
I'm now removing the heart.
Now I'm moving on to cutting out the butthole from The intestines.
This part is really important to not cut.
The intestine right there.
It's full of poop right there,
as you can see. I don't want that on my meat, um,
cause that could contain salmonella or another bacteria.
And then gonna remove that and put that in the gut bucket.
I'm gonna get the chicken a good rinse here.
This chicken still has the neck on
because I did end up parting out this chicken,
so I didn't remove the neck.
But most of my chickens, I do remove the neck,
and then I place them in these bags.
This is specifically made for chickens.
And you can shrink and wrap them under hot water.
I'm gonna make sure that the chicken neck bone
is not poking out the bottom,
so the skin's flapped over that part so it doesn't pierce the bag.
And then they go on ice.